kind of feels like there's nothing
you haven't done but what is a new
challenge
that pieces of a woman pose that you
were eager to tackle for the first time
i'm always a sucker for good writing and
then i i looked at cornell's film
because i wasn't familiar with his work
and i looked at his film white god
that i just loved um
and then when they told me that vanessa
was playing
margaret i said oh this is going to be
fun
i like this and then we met we started
doing rehearsals
and they came to my apartment and
vanessa and i work alike
and it was important to us to to get to
know each other so we could relate in a
mother-daughter way which we did
she spent the night at my apartment and
i
cooked her dinner and cooked her
breakfast in the morning and
we talked in our pajamas and had a
pajama party and
um we got to know each other
in a in a conversationally
deep way so we could relate and i must
say
it was very easy to feel maternal toward
her because she's such a terrific
person so you know
being able to be in a in a story with
somebody like that that you love
but you oppose that you disapprove of
the way they're
handling a situation that's a challenge
you know where you
you don't want to be a harassing mother
but at the same time what you think is
best for your daughter she doesn't
necessarily think is best for her
so there's a conflict so you know you're
in and out of the conflict you
love the actress and the person and you
love the character
but you're in conflict with each other
when you work together so it's a
delicate and complicated um process to
go through
that back and forth is definitely a
standout element of the film and
one of my favorite scenes in it is the
heated conversation you two have at the
family get-together
and also your monologue there and i
guess especially with that
when you're delivering a monologue like
that what can vanessa do in that moment
for you as a scene partner to
bring the best out of you and make the
most of your work well
for one thing she said to me i didn't
realize
until afterwards that
she was having trouble understanding why
she finally goes to court
because she's resisting going to court
and she didn't know how she was going to
get from that scene to the going to
court scene
and actually appearing in court and so
before i went on she said to
me make me go to court
and i mean just before i did the speech
and
i did the speech and speech had its own
reality and energy and
um kind of force field
you know where it came out of me and i
finished it
and then and that split second i
remembered what she said and i did not
feel i had made her go to court
and so i kept going
and i said you must speak your truth you
tell people how it is for you how you're
feeling
if you don't do that if you don't get it
out of you
whatever i said because i don't know
what i said
um it just came out it had its own
reality we were in the scene
and i asked her later
if i helped her to go to court she said
i did
so it was a partnership in there
where um she told me what she needed
i did my best to provide it it worked
for her
and we both benefited from the
relationship
that we had built over the course of
the shoot you feel that big time when
you're watching the movie so
so great success on that beat i have a
martin scorsese question to wrap
with here because i'll never forget what
you said
about him not knowing anything about
women but being willing to learn
on alice doesn't live here anymore and i
know this is a different situation given
the personal nature of the material but
i was wondering if you saw a similar
eagerness to learn from cornell while
making pieces of a woman
well they're very different people and
cornell is much more introverted
than marty is and i had asked marty a
direct question
what he knew about women so the
situation
is different and cornell is
his partner katya um
they have double credit for the film
you know it's not like he directed and
she wrote they
they are credited for producing this
film together
um he's uh he's a quiet person
i don't know what he knows about women
i don't know what he but when i see
their relationship i
feel that they're have a deep connection
i don't i don't talk to cornell the way
i've talked to marty in the past because
he's
he's a quieter more introverted person
but the depth is there did you ever get
the chance to
talk to marty after he joined this film
i know it was late in the game but
he he eventually became an ep on it
he did because he saw the film and he
liked it so much and he wanted to make
sure
that cornell was an unknown director
that the right people got to see it
and we did an interview where he
interviewed the cast
and it was so wonderful to
hear him talk about the film because he
has such an
eye that he picked up on things that i
never heard anybody else pick up on
um and he has such an appreciation
of the of the art of moviemaking
that um you feel
seen it feels like your work is seen
when he talks about it he's such a
master now
thank you so much for your time i have a
million questions i could ask you but i
gotta wrap it up so congratulations and
i'm rooting for you this season thank
you i appreciate that